this video is sponsored by brilliant dog
we've heard about the polar vortex
dangerous and deadly polar vortex the
polar vortex this weather event is
called a polar vortex is the polar
vortex caused by climate change no now
let's ask some better questions like
what actually is the polar vortex
because seemingly nobody in the press
understands what it actually is
and secondly has the frequency of cold
air outbreaks associated with some
stratospheric warming changed in the
presence of anthropogenic climate change
or more bluntly is this cold weather
caused by climate change to begin with
this is not the polar vortex neither is
this all this this was the polar vortex
I say was because that's what it looked
like at the start of December the polar
vortex is a feature that forms in the
stratosphere every winter in both the
northern and southern hemispheres
between about 20 and 80 kilometers above
the surface
it's a circulation of seriously strong
winds that go around the pole in the
middle atmosphere in a way it's the
largest storm in the world the size of a
continent that naturally forms every
year rotating around the pole just to
reiterate this isn't at the surface you
are not living through the polar vortex
or in the polar vortex or in the time of
the polar vortex the polar vortex is a
big zonal circulation in the
stratosphere that forms every year
that's all so what does it have to do
with weather at the surface well every
now and again about seven times every
decade on average since the 1950s it
tears itself apart in an event called a
sudden stratospheric warming and I made
a video explaining that process the last
time that that happened in March 2018
this time around the vortex split apart
around Christmastime and this had a
bunch of knock-on effects on the
atmosphere closer to the surface after a
couple of weeks again this is explained
in that video in much more detail or
alternatively you could read my thesis
on the subject but crudely speaking in
the aftermath of a sudden stratospheric
warming the mean latitude of the jet
stream moves further south the jet
stream if you remember is the narrow
fast-moving River
in the lower atmosphere which separates
freezing polar air from warmer
mid-latitude air the jet stream waves
and Wiggles around and whether it's
north or south of you largely determines
if you experience warm or cold weather
at the surface
do you remember warm weather mr. Frodo
after the polar vortex experiences a
sudden warming and splits apart the jet
stream moves further south and the
Wiggles in it get bigger that allows for
freezing arctic air to spill further
south than normal and we see the kind of
extreme cold in the mid latitudes that
we've seen in Europe and to a much
greater extent in America I'm sorry what
so the real question you should be
asking is is the stratospheric polar
vortex tearing itself apart in a
southern stratospheric warming more
frequently now the climate is warming
was this weather event made more likely
by climate change let me explain why the
answer is yes and then I'll show you why
the answer is no the polar vortex is
caused by a combination of the thermal
wind effect and the temperature gradient
between the pole and the equator the
bigger the difference in temperature
between the pole and the equator the
stronger the polar vortex will be and
the stronger the vortex is the less
likely it is to undergo a sudden warming
and split apart now while the global
average temperature is increasing due to
human interference with the climate it
isn't happening at the same rate
everywhere the poles are warming much
faster than the rest of the world an
effect called Arctic amplification so
the temperature difference between the
pole and the equator is getting smaller
leading to a weaker polar vortex which
undergoes certain warming's more easily
leading to more frequent outbreaks of
extremely cold air the last such
outbreak was less than a year ago with
the beast from the east and so you might
argue that we've already seen an
increase in frequency of these events to
events in less than two years is more
frequent than seven in ten years
but you'd be wrong this big paper was
headed up by dr. Blanca Arthur go Ana
and it looked at changes in the behavior
of the polar vortex predicted by a
number of complex climate models forced
by anthropogenic climate change using a
variety of metrics
the paper found no evidence of
statistically significant future changes
to the behavior of the vortex hey Vsauce
editing Simon here just wanted to
interject because something I didn't
mention when I filmed this video is that
not all scientists will agree with the
conclusions of this paper there is a
minority view that some warnings will
get more frequently climate change I
think that this paper is correct and
full disclosure I used to work with
blanket at the University of Exeter but
just for completeness I thought I'd
mention that also that the jet stream
might get wavy under climate change in
general but that's not what this video
is about I'll leave a reference down
there if people are interested but this
video is about linking the current cold
snap to the recent sudden warming and
clearing up the confusion about the
polar vortex so okay that's it back to
the video no changes in the frequency of
southern warnings or changes in the
strength of the vortex and to quote the
paper the analysis of other features of
sudden stratospheric warming x' besides
the mean frequencies supports the key
finding of the study the anthropogenic
forcings will not affect sudden
stratospheric warming over the 21st
century this may seem a bit
counterintuitive given what I just told
you about how the equator to pole
temperature difference forces the polar
vortex but remember that nothing in the
atmosphere is truly simple as a
multitude of different phenomena talking
to each other interacting in complex
ways and climate change forces them all
in different directions for example the
surface temperatures and the climate
change are increasing but the
temperature of the stratosphere is
actually cooling and it may well be that
just those two phenomena cancel each
other out as far as the polar vortex is
concerned it's also worth noting as the
authors do that we only have about 50
years of observations of the polar
vortex which is why it's dangerous to
draw conclusions about the frequency of
some warming's because we just haven't
seen that many it may well be that the
past 50 years are anomalous and have
loads of sudden warming's for some
reason and so that will skew the
conclusions of the paper but that's all
the data we have for the time being we
just got to wait and see what happens
for the time being science indicates
that climate change doesn't increase the
frequency of sudden stratospheric
warming and therefore the most recent
sudden warming in December was not made
more likely by climate change
categorically saying whether a
particular weather event was
was by climate change or not is pretty
much impossible but in this case we can
be fairly certain the current extreme
cold resulting from the sudden
stratospheric warming and breakup of the
polar vortex in December is part of
natural variability rather than having
man-made origins for once we didn't
actually cause this particular frozen
mess if you're currently trapped inside
due to the extreme cold then you're
gonna have a lot of free time on your
hands you've already spent some of that
time learning about the science of why
your front garden resembles Hoth so why
not dive deeper and learn more about the
science on brilliant org in particular
you might like to check out they're out
in nature chapter in the physics of the
everyday course which teaches you about
the physics of the world around you
through solving problems and encouraging
you to learn from your mistakes
there are courses on maths science and
computer science at a variety of levels
and if you're stuck inside for a long
time then don't fear there are daily
problems on brilliant which get you to
stretch your logical and scientific
thinking skills come out of the polar
vortex enforced shut down smarter with
brilliant by going to brilliant org
slash Simon Clark and the first 200 of
you to do so will get 20% off your
premium subscription to access their
seriously cool courses thank you for
watching the video if you found the
science and this one interesting then
definitely check out the video I made
last year about sudden stratospheric
warming and if you like the way I make
my science videos then there's a
playlist of them down here check the
description for links citations and
footnotes and thank you again for
watching I'll see you next time
shout outs my phone for being my
hairline pixel 3 it's a bloody good
phone